bevor wir mit diesem wieder anfangen
muss ich sagen dass ich wirklich mit
diesem video jetzt keinen der anderen
youtuber angreifen möchte die das
vielleicht öfter mal machen ich gucke
viele von ihnen selber und ich denke
auch man sollte so einen kleinen spaß
verstehen aber ich will auch gar nicht
so viel verraten
wir fangen direkt an mit dem video sind
rovers club willkommen bayer neuen video
und hab ich mir für heute gesagt ihr
habt euch als auch wirklich so richtig
krass gewünscht so jo alex macht doch
meine folge wo du deine richtig krassen
heftigen sneaker vorstellst die ich mir
neu gegönnt habe oder wie ich länger
schon richtig feier und ab juli gekommen
machst du rein und ich würde sagen dafür
sind auch schon mal direkt die 10.000
likes drin deswegen leicht jetzt schon
mal alle ja dann würde ich sagen wenn
ihr jetzt alle hatte ich gelebt habe ja
fangen wir an mit meinen krassen
sneakern dann sind wirklich die ultra
heftigsten dabei ich behalt natürlich
gehen richtig krasse nciht so bis zum
ende des videos auch damit dass halterin
des videos kommen um hier auch alle weg
bis zum ende des videos schaut deswegen
würde ich sagen fangen wir erstmal mit
einem coolen modell aber ich finde da
geht auf jeden fall auch mehr und zwar
leute sind dass diese hier das sind
richtig keine neue sneaker die habe ich
mir vor zwei wochen gegönnt habe ich so
gerade noch irgendwie im internet
schießen können sind auf jeden fall
richtig nice piegsa das sind hier die
kamera auch direkt erkennen an den
streifen dass es sich um abu gehandelt
das sind die alta skechers und skechers
super bequem auf federleicht ich glaube
die wiege nur so ein kilo oder so das
kind eigentlich voll und die kann man
auch heftig gut zum beispiel zu dieser
jogginghose die ich an ab kombinieren
sieht auf jeden heftig ultras nice aus
und kann ich auf ihren jedem empfehlen
sich die man zu können die an ihn das
skechers 2.4 ich will euch natürlich
auch nicht länger auf die folter spannen
die wachen direkt weiter mit einer
richtig fressen modells verleiht
und zwar moment
das sind die momente ich einfach mal den
linken schuh
das hier sind die neuen nikes die habe
ich noch nicht angezogen habe ich jetzt
fresh exklusiv erst im video ausgepackt
hier wie man drauf sieht die originelle
77 das steht ja auch dafür dass die
original sind kann man auch hier nochmal
perfekt an der sohle erkennen so wer
jetzt hier in den vergan stadt und kreis
dann wäre das ja gefälscht ja auf jeden
fall sind das die nike seventy seven von
mai gibt es auch in schwarz und weiß zu
kaufen ist jetzt in exklusiver männer
studien gibt es natürlich auch wie die
dame feiere ich mega kann ich auch jedem
empfehlen okay leute und jetzt kommen
wir zu wirklich einem richtig guten
favoriten von mir diese schuhe sind
ultra sie tragen zurzeit so gerne auf
bäume in der schule die leute feiern
mich wenn ich diese schuhe anziehen ich
bin einfach der boss fast aus und
schickt also gebt euch mal diese schuhe
das sind die top-3 tags von puma
wirklich ultra meisterschule kann man
auch perfekt wie dieser jogging hose
anziehen aber natürlich auch zu einer
normalen jeans oder auch eine bodenlose
wenn man mal wieder ein bisschen im
sandkasten spielen geht richtig geiler
schurig zeigt euch den grad nochmal hier
sieht richtig richtig geiles kann ich
eben auf jedem empfehlen empfehlen
empfehlen ja genau
okay leute und jetzt sind wir wirklich
zu dem moment gekommen wo er alle noch
mal ordentlich auf den like-button hauen
müsst meldet euch doch mal mit eurem
zweiten schritt an und lasse auch ein
daumen nach oben da wir kommen zum
wirklich heftigsten schuh der hat 1400
euro gekostet ich packe denn jetzt
exklusiv hier im video aus der ist
richtig krass da sieht man auch schon
hier die marke rallye
das sind ja es ist eine neue marke von
neu ist dass auch ist wirklich heftig
geil ist in zusammenarbeit mit justin
bieber design vor
nein
kleinteilig matratze sohle
da muss ich mal kurz drüber lecken er
ist der wohl egal halte ich anderen
konzept das habe ich gerade ernsthaft in
mein zimmer groß das ist wirklich ein
geiler schuh
gebt euch diese sohle das ist ja in
zurzeit habe ich wieder schlag zu hole
ich mir und ja wenn ich damit jetzt in
die schule gehen werde weil sie jetzt
schon wieder die reaktionen seien werden
hier noch mal der lauf sich nike weit
big soul also fix ohne deswegen halt
kann man sich geben ist nice so sieht er
noch mal an meinen füßen daraus auf
jeden fall ein fetter schuh turner
wieder leuchtet das war meine wirklich
krasse schuhsammlung wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann sage ich mal kommen
wie knacken die 15.000 likes bald allem
einen leicht nach oben da rein und
vielleicht ein bisschen spaß beiseite
also wirklich gefallen hat dann lass mir
gerne doch noch unklar
lass dir einen daumen nach unten reicht
und wenn ich euch wirklich mal meine
normalen schule zeigen soll die ich
denke ich zurzeit tragen wenn man die
kommentare schreiben
oder mir sonst wie beweisen dann gibt's
dazu auf jeden fall auch noch ein video
also mein richtigen sneaker da habe ich
ein paar coole am start und ich hoffe
dies wieder oder ich trotzdem gefallen
instagram stück weil es angewendet hier
oben ist jetzt weiter mit meinem match
video
sorry mama für dieses video schaut euch
an wir sehen uns dann am nächsten
dienstag wieder hardware leute
vielleicht auch erst am mittwoch kommt
daran